this is Lucy James reading for reviewer
Richard Wakeling the first boss fight in
wolong Fallen Dynasty is right up there
with the toughest first bosses in video
game history this opening battle hits
you against zhanglian of the yellow
turbans as you clash in a kinetic
two-phase fight to the death it's an
intense skill check that challenges your
prowess of wollongong's mechanics almost
immediately in many ways it feels like a
rite of passage for the rest of the game
and a bold statement of intent from
developer team Ninja
[Music]
I initially loved how it forced me to
adapt to the demands of the game's
particular brand of souls like combat
yet the further I progressed the more
this feeling dissipated as I realized
that this introductory struggle was
little more than an unbalanced outlier
providing a much Sterner test than the
bosses following it for many this sudden
difficulty Spike will be a barrier to
entry halting progress a mere 10 minutes
into the game it's a shame warlong
begins with such a sturdy roadblock not
least because this initial undertaking
isn't indicative of the rest of the game
moving forward in fact outside of this
first boss team ninja has crafted one of
the more approachable Souls likes in
what is a traditionally challenging
genre I didn't encounter another boss
fight on par with Zhang Leon's
difficulty until roughly 15 hours into
wollongong's campaign most of the bosses
in between were a relative Cakewalk to
the point where I was able to cut down
each one on my first attempt usually in
under a minute I still had fun
dispatching every single one but the
ease with which I was able to do so
makes them lose some of their luster and
reinforces the notion that the first
boss is at odds with the rest of the
game
actually a new way to the Future opens
the battle with Zhang Mian sets up
expectations that never come to fruition
particularly when other fights allow you
to summon help from either AI or human
teammates team ninja has experience
developing difficult games of course
with the likes of Ninja Gaiden and Neo
under its belt elements of both those
games are present in well long yet its
combat feels like a streamlined offshoot
of from software's Sakura Shadows died
twice putting an emphasis on deflecting
attacks and breaking your opponent's
stance I say it's streamlined because
while enemies frequently unleash
powerful unblockable attacks you only
need to deflect them by nailing the
timing of a single button press there
aren't any sweep or grab attacks
requiring different techniques to
counter and avoid so it doesn't have the
same kind of depth the timing window to
deflect is relatively generous and these
attacks known as critical blows are
clearly telegraphed so it doesn't take
long before your misdirecting strikes
left right and center the challenge
comes from being able to wreck recognize
which attack is coming and knowing when
to time the deflection so you're not too
early or too late you can block regular
physical attacks and Dodge out of danger
as well but mastering the deflect
mechanic is the optimal way to succeed
plus nothing beats the satisfaction of
parrying an incoming blow and seeing the
sparks fly as steel collides with steel
Wollongong doesn't utilize a traditional
stamina system to bring you in instead
you have a spirit gauge that either
decreases or increases depending on your
actions you can build it by striking
enemies and deflecting their attacks
then consume this positive spirit to
increase the power of your offense
actions like dodging mistiming
deflections performing weapon specific
special moves and casting Wizardry
spells or decrease your spirit as does
sustaining damage from an enemy attack
if your spirit is in the negative and
you take a hit that pushes the gauge to
the lower limit you become defenseless
for a short period of time this creates
a balancing act where you want to build
up an positive spirit to make full use
of your repertoire without succumbing to
this staggered State crucially each
enemy you fight also has a spirit gauge
of its own so skirmishes often focus on
whittling down your foe's defenses as
opposed to concentrating squarely on
damaging their health bar
you can lower the enemy's Spirit by
simply attacking them but utilizing
special moves and deflections carrying
critical blows in particular will
significantly deplete it once their
Spirit gauge hits the lower limit
they'll enter a stunned State giving you
ample opportunity to unleash a
devastating fatal strike that wipes out
a chunk of their health the variety of
different enemy types you'll face
doesn't make this easy especially when
you're dealing with multiple opponents
at the same time but wolong's learning
curve isn't particularly steep once it
all clicks combat falls into this
thrilling back and forth Groove built
around stylish deflections and quick
bursts of over-the-top violence and team
ninja has also implemented a number of
other considerations to ease players in
there are more subtle ways while long
softens The Experience compared to other
Souls likes as well battle Flags which
are this game's equivalent of bonfires
replenish all of your health and healing
items the first time you find them
without requiring you to sit down and
rest this means you can get topped
backup and carry on without respawning
all of the enemies you just killed thus
making exploration a tad more inviting
when you do die you only lose half of
the experience points you accumulated up
to that point you can still earn it all
back by killing the enemy the best in
you but only losing half of the full
amount prevents it from feeling like
you're starting back at square one every
time you die these two examples might
not sound like much but they have a
palpable impact on warlong's difficulty
by definitely scaling back on some of
these genres more vexing idiosyncrasies
however it's the inclusion of near
constant AI companions that does the
most to ease up on the usual challenge
wolong puts a dark fantasy spin on the
Three Kingdoms era of Chinese history
similar to how Neo Drew on its
historical Japanese setting and relevant
mythology Wollongong weaves Chinese
mythology and fantasy elements into its
interpretation of this popular period in
China's history as a result you'll fight
alongside the likes of cow cow lubei and
others with one or two NPC Fighters
joining you depending on where they fit
in the story you can still dismiss the
these legendary Warriors if you want to
go it alone and you're also able to
summon up to two allies if you start a
level without any the AI doesn't tend to
dish out too much damage however and it
has a habit of getting stuck on scenery
it has its uses though usually by
keeping enemies busy and ensuring that
you're not overwhelmed when fighting
groups of foes you can also replace
these NPCs with friends if you'd prefer
to play the whole gaming co-op with the
game's difficulty scaling up to
compensate or you can summon random
players to help you take down a tricky
boss or section so there are plenty of
options for those seeking assistance let
us push forward the levels themselves
aren't quite as sprawling as those found
in the Neo series the game is still
split up into distinct levels with
optional sub battles unlocking
throughout the campaign these bite-sized
stages send you back to previously
visited locations where you'll clear a
few rooms face off against waves of
enemies or take on a boss sub battles
don't usually take very long to complete
and you're rewarded with loot and XP so
they are worth doing in terms of level
design rather than featuring long-winded
detours that Circle back on themselves
most of wolong's branching paths lead to
dead ends with higher level enemies and
more loot it's a tad disappointing that
it doesn't regularly tap into the sense
of both relief and wonderment you get
from looping paths but team ninja has
opted for a different approach to
exploration that feels fresh both you
and every opponent you face has a morale
rank that indicates their strength in
battle simply defeating enemies will
raise this rank but it shoots up quicker
if you kill an enemy with a higher
morale rank than yourself warlong still
has a traditional progression system
where you spend XP to level up stats
like health and damage the morale rank
is there to indicate how your strength
compares to the enemies you're fighting
in a single level it resets to zero at
the beginning of each stage so you tend
to find lower level enemies when you
first arrive at a location this isn't
always the case though One path might
contain an imposing figure with a
significantly higher morale rank than
yourself you can still defeat these
enemies but it it's a dicey proposition
as one wrong move is usually more than
enough to kill you it depends on whether
you want to take the risk for the chance
of being rewarded with a significant
boost of your own morale rank increasing
your morale rank also gives you access
to more Wizardry spells these Mystic
techniques can be Unleashed by consuming
Spirits with each one falling into one
of five Elemental categories water wood
fire earth and metal some of these
spells are self-explanatory letting you
conjure the likes of fireballs pointed
icicles and exploding Rock pillars
others are less obvious such as wood
spells being based entirely around
lightning while metal sorcery focuses on
poisonous toxins you can only equip four
at a time which feels somewhat limiting
but these spells do add an extra layer
of depth to combat they're not all
offense based either with some spells
allowing you to strengthen your defenses
by coating yourself in rocks or restore
lost Health by dealing damage to enemies
there's also a rock paper scissors
mechanic at play where wood overcomes
Earth overcomes water and so on but it's
not something I ever really noticed you
can deflect Elemental attacks with your
weapons so I was never compelled to go
out of my way to counter a magic using
enemy with spells of my own
volong has a fairly large assortment of
different weapon types ranging from
Street Sabers and dual blades to pole
arms and great wooden hammers while the
basic move set is the same for each
Armament within a single weapon type
each individual weapon feels distinct
because of its unique martial arts these
special moves are flashy melee attacks
that are stronger than regular attacks
caveat is they consume a portion of the
spirit gauge with each use some of these
martial arts are focused on damaging a
single enemy multiple times While others
Excel when against a group or to close
the distance on an opponent they add
another exciting wrinkle to wolong's
combat to the point where you're
incentivized to experiment with weapons
you might not otherwise try
unfortunately the game also suffers from
a few technical issues stuttering and
slow down are both frequent annoyances
on PC where poor optimization ensures
that altering the settings does little
to alleviate these problems I never
encountered a situation where this
hampered my ability to defeat enemies so
timing deflections wasn't affected by it
but it's still disappointing that
another PC release is launching in such
a haphazard state it should be noted
that someone else playing the game on
PS5 didn't encounter the same issues so
it's likely these problems are confined
to PC the fact that wol Long's demo
features the first two levels and
carries your save over to the full game
is a boon for those who might otherwise
be put off it gives you the opportunity
to challenge the first boss for yourself
and find out whether it's the barrier to
entry I imagine it will be for many
players if you can defeat Zhang Leon the
game that follows is a thrilling yet
approachable addition to the souls-like
genre its Parry based combat is
frequently stellar and team ninja has
made a number of smart changes to keep
Wollongong feeling fresh even if there's
always a tinge of familiarity it has its
issues but if you're craving a
fast-paced action RPG built on
satisfying combat roll on takes most of
the right boxes
thank you
[Music]
it is